la bosnie avait dénoncé au début du mois
de mars les retards de livraison du
programme kovacs initiée par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé plus
de deux semaines après être monté au
créneau le pays a enfin reçu ce jeudi sa
première cargaison du mécanisme mondial
destiné à approvisionner les pays
défavorisés
après avoir réceptionné ce jeudi 23 1400
doses du vaccin pfizer bio ntech les
autorités bosniennes ont reçu 26 1402
d'astrazeneca un soulagement alors que
le territoire figure parmi les dix états
où le taux de mortalité dû kobe 19 est
le plus élevé je voudrais exprimer les
condoléances des nations unies à tous
ceux en bosnie herzégovine les familles
et les amis de ceux qui ont perdu leur
vie dans cette pandémie
nous savons que nous sommes confrontés à
une poussée et au pire stade de cette
pandémie
comme nous n'avons pas vu jusqu'à
présent beaucoup d'entre vous et
beaucoup de gens ici en souffrent
relativement épargné durant les premiers
mois de l'épidémie le pays n'a passé
aucune commande directe de vaccins
misant tout sur le programme
d'approvisionnement kovacs supposé
assurer un accès équitable des états
pauvres à la vaccination ce système a
montré ses limites alors que les
tensions liées aux livraisons persistent
notamment en europe
plus d'un million de doses de vaccins
ont été commandées par kovacs pour la
bosnie-herzégovine le tout pour un coût
de 13 millions de dollars payés dès la
fin de l'année 2020 un dispositif de
l'om est financée entre autres par le
royaume uni hydroguides le soutien du
royaume uni et des autres au mécanisme
kovacs a créé un système de livraison
qui maintient des prix bas pour tous le
royaume uni a engagé jusquà présent 1,3
milliard de livres dead pour en finir au
plus vite avec la pandémie dont 548
millions de livres pour le seul
dispositif kovacs t5 micromax face aux
livraisons reportées du mécanisme kovacs
les autorités bosniennes se sont
notamment tourné vers la serbie ou
encore la russie qui leur a livrée
de vingt mille doses du vaccin scouts
nick v des doses qui ont principalement
servi à immuniser le personnel soignant